[Musique]
samedi matin 7h30 devant l'école
internationale de montréal une école
publique
[Musique]
des dizaines d'enfants de 6e année font
la file pour faire l'examen d'admission
beaucoup d'appelés peu d'élus c'est des
enfants qui sont sélectionnés faut avoir
des bonnes notes ça vaut le chapitre et
silke et vous dois je la laisserai c'est
surtout pas de journée juste parce qu'on
habite proches et c'est une école
qu'elle a connue il y en a plus d'une
école comme celle là je pense que tout
le monde a le droit de profiter de ça et
que ça ne soit pas réservé au secteur
privé 450 jeunes convoite l'une des 80
places dans cette école secondaire
publique de la commission scolaire de
montréal l'une des premières écoles
internationales au québec tout le monde
cherche un bon avenir pour les enfants
donc donc je passe un très bon du tout
c'est jaune c'est le slang pour les airs
et la mission la mère de marica bulletin
à l'appui a dû d'abord obtenir un
laissez-passer pour l'examen ils se sont
envolés en deux jours
ça fait un tri au niveau des parents
aussi ceux qui sont organisés ce qu'ils
sont pas ceux qui ont du temps mais
parce que manquer le travail le pourrai
faire la file pour avoir le papier pour
faire l'examen c'est pas tout le monde
qui peut se le permettre
c'était un mercredi matin le marica
lorgne d'autres écoles mais pour sa
maman aux études
l'école publique est le premier choix ça
nous coûterait plus cher
l'envoyer dans le privé que ce que je
fais neuf tentes moment l'école
internationale de montréal n'est pas la
seule école publique à sélectionner les
élèves
plusieurs établissements font la même
chose
par exemple ceux qui proposent des
programmes arts études sport études ou
science et plein air la sélection ne
devrait pas avoir lieu parce que tous
les enfants gagnerait à faire partie de
ces programmes particuliers la
présidente du conseil supérieur de
l'éducation constate que l'école
publique est de plus en plus sélectives
les écoles publiques au début avait créé
des projets partez programme un projet
particulier souvent pour compétitionner
avec l'école privée
ça a bien marché mais ils sont rendus
compte succès c'est bon pour l'école
c'est bon pour les lèvres mais là ça se
multiplient de plus en plus mais ça se
multiplient surtout dans les milieux
favorisés et c'est ce qui est dommage
on pourrait dire qu'une partie de
l'école publique notamment au secondaire
au premier cycle du secondaire est en
train de privatiser par la
multiplication des projets particuliers
surtout ceux qui sont sélectifs et qui
sont coûteux qui sont payants les
experts parlent d'un système à trois
vitesses de priver le public enrichi et
le public régulier le paradoxe est que
dans certains cas c'est plus la
concurrence est élevée plus ce sont les
enseignants et les écoles qui choisit
ses enfants en fonction de la niche
qu'ils ont déterminé les programmes
particuliers se multiplient mais
étrangement le ministère de l'éducation
n'a pas le portrait complet de la
situation
on connaît mal l'étendue de ces
pratiques là à la fois les coûts à la
fois lé degré de sélectivité
on connaît mal l'organisation concrète
des programmes particuliers on attend
tout plein de choses qui peuvent
paraître inquiétant haute ou pas et en
ce sens on aurait certainement besoin
d'un portrait
complet détaillé à la csdm on veut
offrir désormais des programmes
particuliers à un plus grand nombre de
jeunes dans le tiers des écoles
secondaires qui sélectionnent leurs
élèves
on a assoupli les critères il ya une
moyenne générale attendant l'examen puis
après ils vont tirer au sort donc on
partira pas de sens descendant
ça va être vraiment un tirage au sort à
tous ceux qui sont admissibles retour à
l'école internationale
la direction n'a pas voulu commenter les
heureux élus seront tirés au sort parmi
ceux qui ont obtenu 70 % et + à l'examen
ça je trouve ça pas super parce que les
personnes qui ont bien travaillé seront
un peu désavantagé parce que on fera une
pige donc je trouve pas ça lui et ça
s'est bien passé on va à une audition de
danse oui pour l autre école
et secondaire
[Musique]